at the end of the 1800s physicists were
staggered to find there was radiation
coming out of all kinds of things just
dirt and rocks the very first time this
was discovered was with a jar of uranium
salts that was left in a draw overnight
and in the morning a photographic plate
that was next to it had been exposed
even though it had been in the dark all
night so where had the radiation came
from from this stuff uranium salt that
was so to discover that dirt was giving
out radiation there was worse installed
where they discovered that there were
three different types of radiation going
on so they really had no idea what was
what was happening so what do you do as
a scientist you name it so they named it
a radiation be radiation see radiation
wow that's a bit dull really isn't it so
maybe let's go for something more
sciency alpha beta gamma yeah that's
much better
and I've got an example here I've got
some alpha beta and gamma radiation
gamma sources here I also have a Geiger
counter which is a little device that
gives up a click when it detects
radiation so I can hold it over the
source and here you get a lot of clicks
so what are the different types so our
alpha it turned out pretty much
completely blocked by paper whereas the
beta and the gamma makes basically no
difference so if we try lead our alphas
are completely blocked
strontium the beta is pretty much
blocked but our gamma sauce
it makes basically no difference so it
can even go to a thick solid piece of
web and you can still see some things
getting through there so we could try
there's a bit penetrating through so but
I think I must be thicker than lead so
what are our three types of radiation
sciences scientists eventually worked
out that the alpha radiation is matter
so it's two protons two neutrons that's
the nucleus of helium the beta source
gives out electrons and the gamma source
gives out electromagnetic radiation